[موسيقى]
الواقع انه موضوع
الهدنه
نحن كما تعرف عندما تشكل مجلس القياده
الرئاسي كانت الهدنه قائمه وقمنا بتجديد
هذه المدينه من طرف الحكومه الشرعيه
ولكن منذ اثنين اكتوبر الماضي
الميليشيات الحوثيه الارهابيه رفض التمديد
رغم كل الجهود اللي بدلت سواء من الاشقاء
همم في قياده التحالف والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه بدرجه رئيسيه
والمبعوث الاممي والمبعوث الامريكي وجهود
ايضا العمانيه همم بدلت في هذا الاتجاه
ولكن للاسف همم رفضه الحوثيه وحتى هذه
اللحظه
[موسيقى]
ايضا خلال الهدنه كان هناك خروقات
الشهداء والجرحى من الجيش الوطني
والمقاومه والتشكيلات العسكريه في كل
الجبهات ورقم ذلك كنا نتحمل
في الحكومه الشرعيه
[موسيقى]
للسلام والاستقرار الذي سيستفيد منه شعبنا
اليمني في كل مكان
[موسيقى]